قال المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم
المتحده سيفان دو جاري في مقابله مع
الجزيره قال ان مجموع المساعدات المقدمه
الى سوريا التي وصلت الى الامم المتحده
بلغت نحو 19 مليون دولار حتى الان
يسوي
اهلا وصلتنا بعد الاموال وبلغت نحو 19
مليون دولار حتى الان ونامل من الدول
الاعضاء والقطاع الخاص ان يتبرعوا بالمزيد
بصرف النظر عن موقفهم حول الوضع السياسي
في سوريا لابد للجميع ان يتبرع بكرم وسخ
كما اعرب دوجاريك عن الالتزام الامم
المتحده بدعم كل السوريين في جميع المناطق
وقال ان على المجتمع الدولي رفع الصبغه
السياسيه واكد على الحاجه الى مزيد من
المساعدات
من الواضح ان هناك حاجه للمزيد من
المساعدات فلو كنت انا في احدى تلك
المناطق غير الخاضعه لسيطره الحكومه
وتعرضت الى الزلزال فلتمنيت المزيد من
المساعدات فورا استطيع القول اننا ملتزمون
بدعم كل الرجال والنساء والاطفال في سوريا
بافضل ما نستطيع سواء في المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها الحكومه او التي لا تقع تحت
سيطرتها اهم ما يمكن للمجتمع الدولي ان
يفعله عدا عن تقديم المساعدات هو رفع
الصبغه السياسيه عن هذه العمليه